[Applause]
[Music]
give me one minute and i'll show you how
security command center can help you
secure and manage risk for your google
cloud environment security command
center is a native security and risk
management platform for google cloud
that helps continuously monitor your
google cloud environment gain visibility
into cloud assets discover
vulnerabilities and misconfigurations
detect or respond to threats and
demonstrate compliance based on industry
standards and benchmarks
security command center allows you to
have centralized visibility and control
over your resources with security
command center you can easily understand
the resources that are deployed and
managed and see which resources have
been added or removed
security command center also allows you
to identify security misconfigurations
and compliance violations in your google
cloud assets and resolve them by
following actionable recommendations
you can detect threats happening against
your google cloud platform with built-in
log analytics and threats targeting your
gke workloads with runtime
instrumentation
security command center premium provides
enterprise security capabilities which
you can access by contacting google
cloud sales team so next time you're
looking to secure and manage risks for
your google cloud environment take a
minute to look at security command
center to learn more check out
cloud.google.com slash security command
center
[Music]